Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Si te han operado alguna vez,
quizá recuerdes cómo empezaste
a contar hacia atrás desde diez,
nueve,
ocho,
y luego despertar tras la cirugía
antes de incluso llegar a cinco.
Y pudiera parecer que estuvieras
dormido, pero no lo estabas.
Estabas bajo anestesia,
que es mucho más complicado.
Estabas inconsciente,
pero también no podías moverte,
tener recuerdos
y, con suerte, tampoco sentir dolor.
Sin poder bloquear
todos esos procesos a la vez,
muchas cirugías serían demasiado
traumáticas para llevarlas a cabo.
Textos médicos antiguos de
Egipto, Asia y Medio Oriente
describen los primeros anestésicos
que contienen cosas como adormidera,
mandrágora
y alcohol.
Hoy en día, los anestesistas
a menudo combinan
agentes locales, inhalatorios
e intravenosos
para conseguir el equilibrio
adecuado para una cirugía.
La anestesia local hace que señales de
dolor de una parte específica del cuerpo
lleguen al cerebro.
El dolor y otros mensajes van por el
sistema nervioso en impulsos eléctricos.
Los anestésicos locales funcionan
creando una barrera eléctrica.
Unen las proteínas en
las membranas neuronales
que permiten a las partículas
cargadas salir y entrar,
y bloquean las partículas
cargadas positivamente.
Un compuesto que hace esto es la cocaína,
cuyos efectos calmantes
fueron descubiertos por accidente
cuando un interno de oftalmología
tuvo cocaína en la lengua.
En ocasiones, esta todavía
se usa como anestésico,
pero muchos de los anestésicos
locales más comunes
tienen una estructura química similar
y funcionan de la misma manera.
Para cirugías mayores en las que
se debe estar inconsciente,
se requiere algo que actúe
en todo el sistema nervioso,
incluyendo el cerebro.
Eso es lo que hacen
los anestésicos inhalatorios.
En la medicina occidental,
el éter dietílico fue el primero común.
Fue mejor conocido como droga recreativa
hasta que los médicos empezaron a ver
que a veces la gente no percibía
las lesiones que tenía
bajo su influencia.
En la década de 1840, empezaron
a sedar pacientes con éter
durante las extracciones dentales
y las cirugías.
El óxido nitroso se hizo popular
en las décadas siguientes
y todavía se usa hoy en día.
aunque los derivados del éter,
como el sevoflurano, sean más comunes.
La anestesia por inhalación se
complementa con anestesia intravenosa,
desarrollada en la década de 1870.
Entre los agentes intravenosos comunes
están los sedantes como el propofol,
que inducen la inconsciencia,
y opioides, como el fentanil
que reducen el dolor.
Estos anestésicos generales
también parecen funcionar
al afectar las señales eléctricas
en el sistema nervioso.
Normalmente, las señales eléctricas
del cerebro son un coro caótico
de diferentes partes del cerebro
que se comunican entre sí.
Esa conectividad te mantiene
despierto y consciente.
Pero cuando alguien está anestesiado,
esas señales se vuelven
más tranquilas y más organizadas,
lo que sugiere que
diferentes partes del cerebro
ya no se comunican entre sí.
Hay muchas cosas que todavía no sabemos
sobre cómo sucede esto exactamente.
Varios anestésicos se unen al receptor
GABA-A en las neuronas del cerebro.
Ellos tienen la puerta abierta,
y dejan fluir las partículas cargadas
negativamente en la célula.
La carga negativa se acumula
y actúa como un atasco,
evitando que las neuronas
transmitan señales eléctricas.
El sistema nervioso tiene
muchos de estos canales cerrados,
que controlan vías de movimiento,
memoria y conciencia.
La mayoría de los anestésicos
probablemente actúan en más de una,
y no actúan solo
en el sistema nervioso.
Muchos anestésicos también
afectan el corazón,
los pulmones,
y otros órganos vitales.
Igual que los primeros anestésicos,
que contenían venenos conocidos
como la cicuta y el acónito,
los fármacos modernos pueden
tener efectos secundarios graves.
Así que un anestesista tiene que mezclar
los medicamentos en un equilibrio justo
para generar todas
las características de la anestesia,
mientras controla cuidadosamente
las constantes vitales del paciente,
y ajusta la mezcla de fármacos
según sea necesario.
La anestesia es complicada,
pero saber cómo usarla
ha permitido el desarrollo de nuevas
y mejores técnicas quirúrgicas.
Los cirujanos pudieron realizar de forma
rutinaria y segura cesáreas,
reabrir las arterias bloqueadas,
reemplazar hígados y riñones dañados,
y muchas otras operaciones
que salvan vidas.
Y cada año, se desarrollan
nuevas técnicas de anestesia
que asegurarán que más y más pacientes
sobrevivan al trauma de la cirugía.